so you think you like mushrooms
well this man has cultivated hundreds
and thousands of mushrooms from dozens
of species teaching himself how to turn
them into extracts tinctures and even
DNA barcoding them I am that I am I'm a
94 model human they call me William
Padilla Brown multi-disciplinary citizen
scientist founder of mycosymbiotics and
microfest
[Music]
how many mushrooms do you think you've
grown or cultivated like individual
mushrooms holy sheesh
I believe I've cultivated about 38
species of mushrooms
I can't even go outside saying I run a
mushroom business without somebody
saying oh what kind of mushrooms or like
asking about magic mushrooms or
something like that you know my response
is all mushrooms are magic
in the pursuit of the magic of fungi
William has to take his work far from
the hum of electric lights
we're here in central Pennsylvania in
one of these beautiful Hemlock dominant
forests on the Appalachian range along
the Susquehanna River we can find really
good specimens out here that we can
bring back to our lab to increase our
genetic diversity that we have available
to our Farmers here in the U.S
these are coral mushrooms some people
call these the crown tip Coral but
there's a lot of species variation in
this type of mushroom these are
saprophytic mushrooms they'll generally
grow on dead and dying materials like
these logs some cultures and some people
will eat these have not eaten this one
they look cool though
I think that there has been a fear of
mushrooms I think there's a lot of
people that think mushrooms are like
toxic but the more you spend time with
something that you think is weird the
more it becomes something that you
understand
William continues to eye the forest
floor as he hikes his vision attuned to
spotting these small natural Marvels at
a distance we're looking at a display of
golden thread cordyceps is the common
name there you go you can see it was
growing on this little truffle ball
for certain mushrooms we carry them
around in bags like this so that their
spores are released I designed this bag
with a friend so that it's completely
mesh and all the spores can come out
pores are the reproductive cells of
mushrooms super tiny they're really good
at getting around and about on their own
here we have lactofluce volumis this is
a delicious Choice edible of the summer
season here in Pennsylvania I like to
make chili with these these mushrooms
are really fun because if you cut them
along the gills you'll see that they
start to produce a latex but when you
cook it it all kind of just goes away
Woody's found so far today is just a
fraction of the mushrooms William
cultivates turkey tail mushrooms
tremidi's Versa color these mushrooms
can be found all around the world these
mushrooms are called versacolor because
they have a variety of colors that you
can find on the top but they will
generally be white on the bottom unless
they are starting to get a little bit
old these mushrooms are highly valued
for their immunological support here we
have our local reishi Ganoderma Suge
grows on the hemlock tree this is known
as the mushroom of immortality and used
in teas and valued for its antioxidant
effects we got our good old oyster
mushrooms these are one of the more
commonly cultivated mushrooms by
hobbyist and citizen scientists because
of how easily it takes to growing on all
sorts of different substrates from
coffee grounds to cardboard oyster
mushroom is your guy
wow this place is popping as William
continues to forge he's about to make an
exciting Discovery so this is exactly
what we were looking for cortisol
Terrace is the most valuable mushroom
that I can come in here and leave with I
could leave with dinner but I can leave
with this mushroom which we can take
back to our laboratory breed out new
cultures for people to farm so we can
create value for ourselves other people
can create value for their families a
lot more than just taking home a couple
mushrooms for a meal these mushrooms are
entomopathogenic which means that they
grow on insects we generally find them
on moth Pupa here in Pennsylvania
generally the orange tip Oak warm moth
so we want to dig that whole thing up
you can actually get a clone of the
mushroom from the insect because the
insect is like completely mummified in
mycelium
sick
great foray we found exactly what we
were looking for I got two different
types of cordyceps and a little bit of
food so we can take everything back to
the lab and get some nice clones get
some spores going we can start growing
and uh doing some business spotting and
harvesting mushrooms may seem second
nature to William
but his deep well of insight and
knowledge didn't happen overnight
when I was 16 I dropped out of high
school and when I was 17 I got my own
apartment around that time I found it
very imperative to understand the source
of what I was consuming and wanting to
know where my food came from I began
cultivating organic food I started to
see mushrooms and play with them figure
out how to grow them because at that
point in time I was a vegan I realized
that I was developing A literacy around
mycology that not many people had so I
took that information started to gather
as much as I could and made myself very
publicly accessible so that I could
share it with other people and develop
more literacy around mycology so that I
could have more nerds to hang out with
all of his study and dedication has led
William into a scientific familiarity
with fungi that allows him to see and
study what most people cannot William
has to be very precise as he processes
samples from his foraging finds neatly
dissecting and pulling what he needs
with delicacy before coven we were
already using masks in here because you
breathe out a lot of organisms out of
your mouth and your nose that it could
potentially contaminate the work that
you're doing so if you're wondering if
your mass works or not it does you'll
get bacteria on your future issues good
mycelium in the insect is dense in the
mycelium and the mushroom are just very
small to get a piece of mycelium out of
so I'm going to take this scalpel get it
into the stair lines it only needs to be
in there for a few moments and I'm going
to put my cordycep sample onto the
alcohol paper towel gently Mist it with
some isopropyl alcohol
this was in the soil so there's like a
lot of organisms on it I'm going to
slice it in half a long ways so what I'm
doing now is I'm just going for some of
this inner tissue which for cordyceps is
very little it's just a little bit
difficult when the mushroom is so tiny
that's all I need Nature's technology is
incredible this little bit of tissue has
enough to replicate the entire organism
cloning and growing mushrooms is
complicated enough as it is but
William's recent study is into the DNA
of mushrooms themselves I discovered
that there are now portable DNA
sequencers and that is incredible I got
super inspired and I used one of the
stimulus checks to purchase one and then
I spent the month teaching myself how to
work with polymerase Chain Reaction gel
electrophoresis and DNA sequencing
now that these things are becoming more
commonplace we're going to reach a
different type of awareness that this is
just a story all life is just a story
and William continues telling these
stories through his research into rooms
and exploration of the mushroom
Community I hope that my work encourages
more people to take their education into
their own hands and start to operate
from a more decentralized standpoint
like the mycelium does the mycelium
doesn't just put all of its energy into
the center it's all distributed
throughout and I think that this way is
more resilient as an individual that
looks to mimic nature mimic natural
designs that have been perfected over
millions of years I think that working
with these types of systems that we see
with the mushrooms may prove to be very
effective for some of our human systems
that have been very flawed